as you mentioned so you're your father
and brother were killed in a suicide
bombing by Islamic extremists I'm
curious as someone that knows this area
of the world intimately one of the
debates we've had on this show for the
last eight months or so is trying to
parse out how much of terrorism is
related to doctrine versus sort of the
geopolitical realities meaning the
actual doctrine of Islam and what it may
say about infidels and things like that
versus people that are expressing a
geopolitical need for whatever I'm how
much do you think do you think it's
50/50 do you think it depends on the
person what's your general take on that
I do think it's a combination I agree
with that the percentages may vary
according to country and maybe even
according to the movement in that
country if I can give you an example in
Isis in Iraq it's actually a marriage
between Isis which was born out of
al-qaeda so it's the Islamist extremists
who interpret the Quran in their own
weird way and you can interpret the
Quran in a million ways so it's those
Islamist extremists but they have allied
with the Baathists the the bosses
Baathists who used to be with Saddam who
were responsible for chemical weapons
for genocide for torture throwing people
off buildings we see those same tactics
it's the same people so the two of them
have married together if you like
the Baathists want to come back to power
in Iraq the Islamist extremists want a
Caliphate and it's a marriage of
convenience
using the geopolitical situation but
also using Islam their version of Islam
as a tool yeah so that brings me to
Turkey speaking of marriages of
convenience or inconvenience because
Turkey I find is in a very strange
position there a NATO ally and yet we
know that they're cracking down on all
kinds of press freedoms and things
things like that they've treated the
Kurdish people very poorly I correct me
if I'm wrong they certain letters I
think W and Q
we're not allowed to be used in Turkish
schools because those are letters that
are used by Kurds is that correct I
believe some letters were not allowed to
be used when they were given in names
because they were not in the Turkish
alphabet so essentially that meant that
Kurdish names were banned but turkeys
made a lot of progress on these things
okay so how then so it seems to me and
police correct me if I'm wrong that on
one hand the the Kurds are on the ground
fighting Isis and at the same time the
Kurds are being bombed by turkey and I
know that's a very complex relationship
because there occurred that live in
Turkey that do have rights and vote and
things like that so and you know the
Kurds in Turkey don't necessarily want
the exact same things that the Kurds in
Iraq want but it seems to me the turkeys
playing both sides of this thing I think
Turkey's main focus is Syria turkey
wants to be rid of asset that is
president Erdogan's priority so I think
most of many of turkeys actions can be
seen through that prism turkey does have
a very large Kurdish population I mean
some people say 20 million some say 30
million Istanbul is arguably the largest
Kurdish city in the world with 3 million
Kurds living there and and those people
demand their rights as they should but
Turkey has made a lot of progress as I
said particularly under Prime Minister
Erdogan when he was Prime Minister
Turkey decriminalized the Kurdish
language there's now a Kurdish TV
station at least one coach TV station
that state-run a lot of progress was
made and there was even the peace
initiative that was that started I
believe in 2012 to really try to have a
dialogue with the Kurdish community
inside Turkey and we all welcome that
because we need Ankara and the Kurdish
population in Turkey to have a peace
settlement among themselves so that they
can get on with things but unfortunately
we've seen a reverse
many of those steps that were taken
they've unraveled and now there is huge
tension in Turkey between the Kurdish
population and Ankara right so that
basically explains so if turkey's end
goal is to get rid of Assad it explains
why they're bombing the Kurds who are
fighting Isis right I mean it that then
makes sense yes I think it's partly that
but also Turkey accuses the Kurds in
Syria of being part of the PKK which is
what Turkey designates as a terrorist
organization yeah can you explain the
difference between the PKK and the
Kurdish regional government for people
that are getting confused by all the
letters yes I just say discovery is
complex so the PKK is a an organization
in Kurdistan in Turkey so it's a Turkish
based Turkey based organization it
started out in the 70s 80s and it's
really been at war with the Turkish
state ever since and we have argued
Kurdistan Region in Iraq we have argued
both with the PKK and with Ankara you
two have been fighting for three decades
PKK is not going to wipe out the Turkish
army right right and the Turkish army
has not been able to wipe out the PKK
after 30 years so clearly you need to
get down sit down to the negotiating
table and this is where the peace
initiative began a few years ago and we
in Iraqi Kurdistan actually played an
instrumental role in bringing the two
sides together so the PKK is really an
issue in Turkey Iraqi Kurdistan we are
within the Iraqi border we have our own
Parliament we have our own government we
have representatives abroad like myself
and Iraqi Kurdistan is the only part of
greater Kurdistan where we have that
autonomy we have government we have
president prime minister yeah it's
fascinating to me that so you guys are
sort of as part of the occurred
regional government you guys are sort of
caught between the PKK and the Turkish
government in a way because they don't
necessarily want the PKK doesn't
necessarily want the exact same things
you want perhaps right and you don't
necessarily want the same things that
the Turkish government wants so you're
you're sort of caught and I suspect this
is probably the same way with Kurds that
live in Iran and Syria and all over the
place that you're trying to mitigate all
of these different relationships because
you've got people spread across four
countries you're absolutely right at the
end of the day were all Kurds and we are
related by blood in my own family of
course I'm an Iraqi Kurds that's where I
was born my parents were born but I have
many relatives in Syria in Turkey and my
husband is from Iranian Kurdistan
so just in my family I have relatives
everywhere and I look at them as uncle
so-and-so auntie so-and-so I don't think
of them as that Iranian or that right
right but the reality is we still have
those borders so there are two realities
for all of us Kurds we live with two
realities one is at the basic level the
family level we're all linked and the
other is the borders that are
international and we have to live with
those and so that does sometimes create
contradictions and conflicts conflicts
in your mind I mean right where of
course the Kurds wherever they are
should have their rights protected
should be able to speak their language
educate children and encourage should
have representation politically and so
on this is what we believe in Iraqi
Kurdistan and this is what we encourage
everywhere but we also encourage them to
do it through peaceful means to do it
through election where possible and in
Turkey and a Kurdish party did very well
in the elections in 2015 they managed to
get over the 10% threshold so for the
first time there is a Kurdish political
party elected to the Turkish Parliament
so these are all signs of progress but
definitely there's huge tension in
Turkey right now in
and we hope that that can be reversed
yeah so we should talk about Iran a
little bit before we finish up because
it seems Iran is sort of the the country
of the time right now their their
influence seems to be growing
you know they we made the the nuclear
deal we'll see what happens with that so
how many Kurds are actually in Iran and
how are they treated there in Iran
they're about 12 million Kurds so they
are a very very large minority and
politically as a movement very active
many Iranian Kurds are actually in Iraqi
Kurdistan just working there or living
there some of the political parties the
Kurdish political parties of Iran are
now based in Iraqi Kurdistan because
they have the freedom there to come and
go so they can actually go across the
border they can go from Iran into
Kurdish controlled Iraq the political
parties there based in Kurdish
controlled Iraq ordinary individuals yes
they can come and go and in fact many
tourists come from Iran to Iraqi
Kurdistan um Iran's relationship with
all of its minorities not just the Kurds
but there are as arees Arabs many many
minorities is very delicate Iran is very
worried about fragmentation or even the
word federalism as a kind of a
federation so Iran is always very
concerned about any of its minorities
making any noises you know the situation
for Iranian Kurds can be very difficult
many young Iranian Kurds are executed
when told the charges are drug-related
others say no it's political sir but
from our point of view Iraqi Kurdistan
as you said earlier we have to balance
so many things one of the things that we
have to balance is a cooperative
relationship with Iran and Turkey
because they're our neighbors we do
trade with them we rely on them
our oil is exported through turkey so we
need to have good relationships with our
neighbors right so it never really hit
me before in this way but now it seems
to me there's five parties here trying
to figure this out
there is the the Kurds that are in Iraq
in the in Kurdistan of Iraq that's one
then there's the people that are in Iran
the people that are in Iraq the people
that are in Syria the people that are in
Turkey and you're trying to manage all
of those things at the same time no
wonder this is such a slow slow process
yes that's true what what about Syria
because we we've sort of glossed over
that means Syria by all estimations as
you said Iraq is a failed state I mean
Syria is at this point more of a failed
state than Iraq so how does that fit
into the equation I think for both Iraq
and Syria was a given now is that a
centralized form of government is over
it doesn't work so in Iraq we and
Kurdistan have been advocating for
federalism true federalism not just on
paper and we're now going to go for a
referendum on self-determination maybe
we will decide to stay with Iraq maybe
we will decide to go completely
independent or maybe we will decide to
have a confederation with Iraq where
Kurdistan and the rest of Iraq are two
sovereign states with equal Authority
what one isn't superior to the other but
they decide to share a border they
decide maybe to have joint cabinet
meetings at government level and so on
in Syria I don't know how exactly it'll
pan out but I think a centralized form
of government
everything controlled by Assad or
whoever comes after him from Damascus
that's over it has to be some kind of
federalism or decentralization or
devolution as they say in Britain and
people have to have local authority that
really is the recipe I think for Syria
and Iraq yeah
well there's so much here and we could
go on forever about all this but I think
we did a nice job of putting together
some of the pieces at least so last
question what can
people do for people that just heard
this and now understand what's going on
there at some level that want to get
involved that wanna you know help and
have their voice heard what can they do
well thank you for giving me the
opportunity to address that question my
pleasure
right now Kurdistan faces three
challenges we have of course the
military challenge the security
challenge fighting Isis it's a long
frontline and every day they're
attacking us so it's not a theoretical
war it's real its life people are
getting killed every day yeah wait real
quick just to add on that because you
mentioned this before we started how
long is that border that you're fighting
along Isis I believe in miles is 650
miles it's just over a thousand
kilometers so literally you're sharing a
border with them and you guys are the
ones fighting them I mean people really
should understand that yeah yes and the
air strikes by the United States and the
coalition very effective but we need
more weapons we need heavy weapons in
particular
Isis has Humvees has tanks it's using
chemical weapons more and more now we
need weapons we need protective gear for
our Peshmerga we also face a
humanitarian crisis our population is
about 5 million that has increased by 30
percent so imagine your town your state
suddenly your population increasing by
30 percent and they're all refugees they
don't know anything they don't you know
they can't work they have nothing you
have to provide electricity healthcare
water and so in Kurdistan until a few
years ago we had 24 hours of electricity
suddenly we don't because we're having
to share it with so many other people so
we need assistance with the humanitarian
crisis and there are many many
organizations that you can donate to
including one that's very close to our
office in Washington DC and then the
other crisis that we face is financial
which impacts everything it impacts how
we help with the refugees in the
displaced and impacts how we help the
Peshmerga fight Isis if you don't have
the money you can't do it
we are lobbying on Capitol Hill in
Washington we're talking to the State
Department in the White House to try and
find a way of helping Kurdistan find its
way out of this financial crisis so
anything that you your viewers can do to
help us on any of those funds we'd be
very grateful
all right well I hope that we gave
people a little bit more of an
understanding of the Kurdish situation I
think we did it was a pleasure chatting
with you and for more on what's going on
with the Kurds and if you want to help
you guys can check out Kurdish relief
fund org and buy on I thank you again
and please if you ever want to share any
more thoughts let me know thank you so
much for having me and I will sue in
your program every success
you